لم تقتصر المعاناه على كسور في الوجه بل
من خوف وترهيب نفسي يزن هذا الطفل الذي
كان على دراجته يلعب كاي طفل لم نتمكن من
اظهار تفاصيل وجهه احتراما لطفولته الام
لا تقوى على الكلام فقد تحاول تخفيف
الالامه
لم يحالف الحظ يزن بوجود اي ناشط لتصفيره
وانقاذه
ولكن هناك اخرون كان بقربهم عدد من ممثلي
هيئات حقوقيه الدوليه
صورا تظهر حجم الخوف الذي يتعرض له
الاطفال وعندما يغلق احد الحواجز يدرسون
في الشارع
هنا في مدرستي قرطبه المطوقه ببؤر
الاستيطانيه رفقنا الطفل قصي عليه ان يعبر
على الاقل اربعه حواجز
داخل البلده القديمه
لا يشعر بالامان
[موسيقى]
وفي المقابل يتجول المستوطنون بين الازقه
والحارات بالسيارات والدراجات ويشير
مختصون وحقوقينا الى معاناه الاطفال
كوابيسه وهلوسه ومن انتهت حقهم حقهم في
التعليم حقهم في الوصول الامن لمدرسه
قرطبه طبعا هذه الاشياء بتعمل مشاكل
سلوكيه ونفسيه عند الطلبه فمن طالب
المجتمع الدولي بتامين حمايه دوليه كان
عملنا خلسه فور اكتشاف امرنا من خلال
كاميرات المراقبه
في كل مكان جاء جنود الاحتلال منعونا من
التصوير والحجه وعدم الحصول على تصريح في
منطقه يفترض انها فلسطينيه ولكنها تحت
سيطرتي الاحتلال والمستطيل
في البلده القديمه وداخل ازقتها اكثر من
100 حاجزا عسكريا اسرائيلي وبوابات حديديه
وساتر ترابك ويعيش هنا في الداخل اكثر من
800 مستوطن تحت حمايه قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي اطفال الخليل يقولون انهم
يتعرضون لشتى اشكال الانتهاكات والخوف من
القتل والترهيب النفسي والجسدي
الجزيره الجزيره